This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Imagine for a moment the year 1800, a doctor is meeting with a patient, most likely in the patient's home. The patient is complaining about shortness of breath, a cough, a fever. The doctor listens to the patient's complaints, asks a ton of questions, scribbles some notes. Producer Emmett Fitzgerald. And the doctor might check the patient's pulse, but unlike today, what's happening inside of the patient is basically unknowable. There's no MRI, no X-rays.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。试想一下1800年，一位医生正在会见病人，很可能是在病人家中。病人抱怨呼吸急促、咳嗽、发烧。医生倾听病人的诉说，问了一大堆问题，潦草地记下一些笔记。制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。医生可能会检查病人的脉搏，但与今天不同的是，病人身体内部发生了什么基本上是不可知的。没有核磁共振，没有X光。
The living body is like a black box that can't be opened. The only way for a doctor to figure out what's wrong with a patient is to ask them. You needed the patient to tell you what was wrong and what they were suffering. So doctors were very interested in the patient's history, the story of what the symptom was, how long it had been there, how it had changed, what made it better, what made it worse. This is Dr. Jacqueline Duffin. I am a hematologist and a historian of medicine at Queen's University. Duffin says that because the patient's story was all the doctor had to go on, the symptoms
活体就像一个无法打开的黑匣子。医生找出病人病因的唯一方法就是询问他们。你需要病人告诉你哪里出了问题，以及他们正在遭受什么痛苦。因此，医生对病人的病史非常感兴趣，即症状的故事、持续了多久、如何变化、什么让它好转、什么让它恶化。这是杰奎琳·达芬医生。我是皇后大学的血液学家和医学历史学家。达芬说，因为病人的故事是医生唯一能依靠的东西，所以症状
were often seen as... Diseases in themselves. So for example, today if you have a fever, you think of it as a symptom of some underlying disease like the flu. But back at the turn of the 19th century, the fever itself was considered the disease. There were all different kinds of fevers, and fever itself was a broad category of diagnosis. Because doctors had no way of connecting symptoms with what was actually going on inside the body. Until someone built a device that would help the doctor open the black box
通常被视为……疾病本身。例如，今天如果你发烧，你会认为它是某种潜在疾病（如流感）的症状。但在19世纪之交，发烧本身就被认为是疾病。有各种各样的发烧，发烧本身就是一个广泛的诊断类别。因为医生没有办法将症状与身体内部实际发生的情况联系起来。直到有人制造了一种能帮助医生打开黑匣子的装置
and travel inside the human body. And suddenly the doctor could hear everything so much more clearly. The heart belongs, the breath. And everything changed. The inventor of this stethoscope was unsurprisingly a doctor. Renee Leineck was born in Brittany in 1781, and he went to medical school in Paris, where he learned to practice percussion, a technique in which the doctor taps their fingers against a patient's chest and listens to the sound, to determine things like if fluid is building up in the patient's lungs.
并进入人体内部。突然间，医生可以更清晰地听到一切。心脏的跳动，呼吸。一切都改变了。这种听诊器的发明者不出所料是一位医生。勒内·拉埃内克于1781年出生在布列塔尼，他在巴黎学习医学，在那里他学会了叩诊，这是一种医生用手指敲击病人胸部并听声音的技术，以确定诸如病人肺部是否有积液等情况。
Lynek uses the technique for years, and in 1816 he's examining a patient and he precusses her torso. But she's a little bit plump, and because she's plump, he's not getting much sound back from percussing. He thought about putting his ear right against the patient's breast, but he decided that that would be inappropriate. So he took a notebook that he had with him, and he rolled it up into a little cylinder,
拉埃内克使用这种技术多年，1816年，他在检查一名病人时叩诊她的躯干。但她有点丰满，因为她很丰满，他从叩诊中得不到多少声音。他想过把耳朵直接贴在病人的胸部，但他认为那样做是不合适的。于是他拿了一个随身携带的笔记本，把它卷成一个小圆筒，
and he put one end on the patient's chest and one end on his ear, and he tells us he was struck by how clearly he could hear a heart beating and her breath sounds. I was satisfied to hear the beating of the heart in a manner that was clearer and more distinct than I had ever heard by direct application of the ear. He was so impressed by the quality of the sound that he set about trying to construct the perfect device for listening to the internal sounds of the body, all based on that same cylinder shape.
他把一端放在病人的胸口，另一端放在自己的耳朵上，他告诉我们，他被自己能如此清晰地听到心跳和呼吸声所震撼。我很高兴能以一种比我以前通过直接贴耳听到的更清晰、更独特的方式听到心跳。他对声音的质量印象深刻，以至于他开始着手尝试制造一种完美的装置来聆听身体内部的声音，所有这些都基于同样的圆筒形状。
People said that he became a cilantro maniac, a cylinder maniac, because he was convinced that the instrument mediating between the two bodies of the patient and the doctor improved what the doctor could hear. He used a lathe to carve cylinders out of wood. And at first he wanted to call his new device the cylinder, but eventually he settled on the stethoscope, which means to explore the chest.
人们说他成了“圆筒狂人”，因为他确信这种在病人和医生两个身体之间进行调节的仪器改善了医生能听到的声音。他用一台车床把木头雕刻成圆筒。起初他想把他的新装置称为“圆筒”，但最终他选择了“听诊器”，意思是“探索胸部”。
But Lynex original stethoscope looks pretty different from the ones we're used to today. It's a long tube-like cylinder. It looks like a small handheld telescope. Lineck started using his new invention to listen to the heart sounds and the breathing sounds of all of the patients in his hospital. And he started to invent words to describe the sounds, because nobody had heard these sounds before. Lineck had invented a way to hear the inner workings of the human body, but that wasn't enough
但拉埃内克的原始听诊器看起来与我们今天习惯使用的非常不同。它是一个长管状的圆筒。它看起来像一个小型的便携式望远镜。拉埃内克开始使用他的新发明来聆听医院里所有病人的心跳声和呼吸声。他开始发明词汇来描述这些声音，因为以前没有人听到过这些声音。拉埃内克发明了一种聆听人体内部运作的方法，但这还不够。
by itself. He wanted to connect the sounds he was hearing in his patients with what was actually happening anatomically inside their bodies. And how do you connect sounds to what's actually happening inside a body? You listen to people right before they die. He ran around the ward listening to all the patients documenting their symptoms, listening to the sounds they made, and then connecting them to the discoveries he would make at their autopsy when they died.
他想把他听到的病人的声音与他们体内解剖学上实际发生的情况联系起来。你如何将声音与身体内部实际发生的情况联系起来？你在人们死前听他们的情况。他在病房里跑来跑去，听所有病人的声音，记录他们的症状，听他们发出的声音，然后把这些声音与他们死后尸检时发现的情况联系起来。
He thought that every abnormal sound he heard with his stethoscope should correspond to an anatomical finding during the autopsy. So that if you hear this sound, it equals that anatomical finding during the autopsy. So that if you hear this sound, it equals that anatomical finding later. So that the stethoscope was a way of practicing the autopsy before the patient became a cadaver. I mean, we're all just future cadavers, right? But the stethoscope gave us a way of looking inside of a body before it was dead to see what was causing a particular medical problem. In a relatively short period of time, Lynek made some key discoveries using his stethoscope.
他认为他用听诊器听到的每一个异常声音都应该对应尸检时的解剖发现。这样，如果你听到这个声音，它就等于尸检时的那个解剖发现。所以听诊器是一种在病人变成尸体之前进行尸检的方法。我的意思是，我们都是未来的尸体，对吧？但听诊器给了我们在身体死亡前观察内部的方法，以查看是什么导致了特定的医疗问题。在相对较短的时间内，拉埃内克利用他的听诊器做出了一些关键发现。
For example, he figured out that when a person has fluid beneath their lungs, they make a sound kind of like a goat. Kind of bleeding sound like this. A sound he called a gofini. He also discovered sounds that tracked with the different stages of tuberculosis, the number one killer in Europe at the time. Lynac published his results, linking different diagnoses with anatomical changes
例如，他发现当一个人的肺部下方有积液时，他们会发出一种类似山羊的声音。一种像这样的咩咩声。他称之为“羊鸣音”。他还发现了与肺结核不同阶段相吻合的声音，这是当时欧洲的第一大杀手。拉埃内克发表了他的研究结果，将不同的诊断与解剖变化联系起来
in the body that could be detected using his new stethoscope. Doctors who were his colleagues loved it. They felt that every disease would eventually be attached to an anatomical finding and anatomical change. Some doctors began using LINEX new device themselves. He even put a diagram of it in his book so you could make your own quite easily or have it made for you by any carpenter. And as these doctors used the stethoscope to make more important
这些变化可以通过他的新听诊器在体内检测到。他的同事医生们很喜欢它。他们认为每一种疾病最终都会与解剖发现和解剖变化联系起来。一些医生开始自己使用拉埃内克的新装置。他甚至在他的书中放了一张图表，这样你就可以很容易地自己制作，或者让任何木匠为你制作。随着这些医生使用听诊器做出更多重要的
discoveries about the body, new categories of disease were created. For example, before the stethoscope, a lot of different ailments were all lumped into one disease called dipsnia, which means shortness of breath. But afterline neck, shortness of breath became a symptom of various heart or lung problems that could be diagnosed using the stethoscope. Medical language completely changed, as doctors invented new anatomical words for diseases like bronchitis, which means the inflammation of the bronchial tubes, the airways that lead to the lungs.
关于身体的发现，新的疾病类别被创造出来了。例如，在听诊器出现之前，许多不同的疾病都被归为一种叫做“呼吸困难”的疾病。但在拉埃内克之后，呼吸困难成为了各种心脏或肺部问题的症状，这些问题可以使用听诊器进行诊断。医学语言完全改变了，医生们为支气管炎等疾病发明了新的解剖学术语，意思是支气管（通往肺部的气道）的炎症。
Little by little, our entire understanding of disease shifted. It became more objective. Diseases went from being constellations of symptoms felt subjectively by the patient to anatomical or chemical alterations inside the body detected by the doctor. This shift in how people thought about disease changed the relationships between doctors and patients with the doctors suddenly having a lot more power.
一点一点地，我们对疾病的整个理解发生了转变。它变得更加客观。疾病从病人主观感受到的症状集合，变成了医生检测到的身体内部的解剖或化学改变。这种人们对疾病看法上的转变改变了医生和病人之间的关系，医生突然拥有了更多的权力。
So before the stethoscope, to be sick you had to feel sick. After the stethoscope, to be sick, the doctor had to find something. It didn't matter what the patient thought, what was wrong with them, it mattered more what the doctor found. Lynack himself actually worried that many doctors were taking his ideas too far. He believed that listening to what patients had to say was still important to understanding disease.
所以在听诊器出现之前，要生病你必须感觉生病。在听诊器出现之后，要生病，医生必须发现一些东西。病人认为自己哪里出了问题并不重要，重要的是医生发现了什么。拉埃内克本人实际上担心许多医生把他的想法推得太远了。他认为倾听病人要说的话对于理解疾病仍然很重要。
But the quest for objective information about disease was underway, and the stethoscope was just the beginning. Then we got X-rays, which do the same thing at the end of the 19th century, and now we have CP scanners and MRIs and PET scans, and all of these marvelous devices are basically trading upon the same paradigm that the stethoscope brought along that we should be able somehow to image the pathological anatomical abnormalities
但对疾病客观信息的追求正在进行中，而听诊器仅仅是个开始。后来我们有了X光，在19世纪末做同样的事情，现在我们有了CT扫描仪、核磁共振和PET扫描，所有这些奇妙的装置基本上都在利用听诊器带来的相同范式，即我们应该能够以某种方式对病理性的解剖异常进行成像
inside the body to reach the diagnosis, whether the patient has any symptoms at all or not. These new technologies have led to so many important discoveries about the human body and disease. Today we can spot tumors before they become life-threatening, and diagnose problems like high blood pressure before it causes heart disease. But there are also patients today who struggle because they've got tons of symptoms, but the doctor can't find anything quote quote-unquote, wrong with them.
进入身体以达成诊断，无论病人是否有任何症状。这些新技术对人体和疾病做出了许多重要的发现。今天，我们可以在肿瘤危及生命之前发现它们，并在高血压导致心脏病之前诊断出问题。但今天也有一些病人感到挣扎，因为他们有大量的症状，但医生却无法发现他们身上有什么“所谓的”问题。
The paradigm shift brought on by the stethoscope has pushed doctors and patients further apart. The doctor is no longer visiting you in your bedroom, interviewing you about every tiny detail of your experience. And sometimes, patients end up feeling like just the collection of data points, rather than a whole human being. Sometimes, patients end up feeling like just the collection of data points, rather than a whole human being. Renee Linek died in 1826 at the age of 45, most likely from tuberculosis, a disease he and his stethoscope helped us understand.
听诊器带来的范式转变将医生和病人推得更远了。医生不再去你的卧室拜访你，询问你经历的每一个微小细节。有时，病人最终感觉自己只是数据点的集合，而不是一个完整的人。有时，病人最终感觉自己只是数据点的集合，而不是一个完整的人。勒内·拉埃内克于1826年去世，享年45岁，很可能是死于肺结核，这是一种他和他的听诊器帮助我们理解的疾病。
It's been 200 years since he first rolled up his notebook and pressed it to that patient's chest. Medicine looks completely different than it did back then. But somehow, the stethoscope has endured. There are certain tools of the trade that we have gotten rid of. So you don't really see doctors carrying around this big black bag. This is Dr. Andrew Bontbach. He's an aphrologist, a kidney doctor, and an assistant professor at the Columbia University College of Physicians and Surgeons.
距离他第一次卷起笔记本并把它按在那个病人的胸口已经过去200年了。医学看起来与当时完全不同。但不知何故，听诊器一直延续了下来。有些我们已经不再使用的行业工具。所以你真的看不到医生随身携带那个黑色的大包。这是安德鲁·邦巴克医生。他是一位肾脏科医生，也是哥伦比亚大学内科和外科医学院的助理教授。
Most doctors nowadays don't carry around reflex hammers unless they're neurologists. Most doctors don't wear that light on their head, but the stethoscope has never really fallen out of practice. But of course, doctors aren't walking around with wooden cylinders anymore. In the 1840s, they began experimenting with flexible tubing, and soon after an Irish physician invented the Bynoral Stethoscope design with two earpieces that we still use. Today, there are a few kinds of specialized stethoscopes for particular types of listening,
现在的医生大多不随身携带反射锤，除非他们是神经科医生。大多数医生不戴那个头灯，但听诊器从未真正停止使用。当然，医生们不再带着木制圆筒走来走去。在19世纪40年代，他们开始尝试使用软管，不久之后，一位爱尔兰医生发明了我们今天仍在使用的双耳听诊器设计。今天，有几种专门用于特定聆听类型的听诊器，
and more recently, companies have developed electronic stethoscopes with enhanced sound quality and the ability to record. But to this day, when you walk into a doctor's office for a routine exam, you can expect to feel the familiar stethoscope sliding along your back. But that could be changing. For almost 200 years, the trusty stethoscope has been at the forefront of the diagnostic
最近，公司开发了具有增强音质和录音功能的电子听诊器。但直到今天，当你走进医生的办公室进行常规检查时，你可以期待感觉到熟悉的听诊器在你的背上滑动。但这可能会改变。近200年来，可靠的听诊器一直处于诊断的最前沿
procedure, constantly hanging around the necks of doctors and often used, but new technology is threatening to exile this old friend to the archives of medical history. Extras and ultrasound have given doctors a clearer window into the body than ever before. And with new portable ultrasound machines, doctors can see an image of a hole in a patient's heart right from the bedside. The rise of portable ultrasound has some doctors arguing that we don't need the stethoscope anymore. They say that if you have that technology, why not use it right away? But ultrasound isn't available in many developing countries. And even in the United States, it's expensive.
程序，经常挂在医生的脖子上，经常被使用，但新技术正威胁着要把这位老朋友流放到医学历史的档案中。X光和超声波给了医生比以往任何时候都更清晰的身体窗口。有了新的便携式超声波机器，医生可以直接在床边看到病人心脏上有一个洞的图像。便携式超声波的兴起让一些医生认为我们不再需要听诊器了。他们说，如果你有那种技术，为什么不马上使用它呢？但超声波在许多发展中国家并不普及。即使在美国，它也很昂贵。
If we eliminated the stethoscope and everybody got an ultrasound at every visit, we would bankrupt our health care system. This is Dr. Dan Bernstein, a cardiologist at Stanford University. He says that when he hears something problematic during the stethoscope exam, he immediately orders an ultrasound.
如果我们淘汰了听诊器，每个人在每次就诊时都进行超声波检查，我们就会让我们的医疗保健系统破产。这是斯坦福大学的心脏病专家丹·伯恩斯坦医生。他说，当他在听诊器检查中听到有问题时，他会立即安排超声波检查。
But do I start with every patient who comes in the emergency room taking out the ultrasound machine looking at the lungs? I think that's not a good use of that technology. Right now, he says the stethoscope functions as a screening tool, so that patients don't need to go get an expensive ultrasound unless they need one. Still, there's no denying that advanced imaging
但我是否应该从每个走进急诊室的病人开始，拿出超声波机器检查肺部？我认为这不是对该技术的有效利用。目前，他说听诊器作为一种筛查工具，这样病人就不需要去进行昂贵的超声波检查，除非他们需要。尽管如此，不可否认的是，先进的成像技术
has changed the instrument's role. Dr. Andrew Bombak says that medical students today aren't as good at listening to the body as they once were. And across the board, doctors rely less on the stethoscope to make a diagnosis. It's become almost a ritual more than a actual tool of the trade in terms of helping us make diagnosis. Recently, one of Dr. Bombak's most respected colleagues asked to borrow a stethoscope. And Bombak was embarrassed because the only one he had within that day was this cheap plastic disposable thing. But he handed it over anyway.
已经改变了该仪器的作用。安德鲁·邦巴克医生说，今天的医学生在聆听身体方面不如以前那么好了。总的来说，医生在做出诊断时对听诊器的依赖程度降低了。它几乎变成了一种仪式，而不是一种在帮助我们做出诊断方面的实际行业工具。最近，邦巴克医生最受尊敬的同事之一借用了一个听诊器。邦巴克感到很尴尬，因为他那天手头唯一的听诊器就是那个廉价的塑料一次性东西。但他还是把它递了过去。
And he said, oh yeah, thanks, that's perfect. He knew me. And as he was walking away, he's like, you know, patients just expect you to have this when you see them. He's like, I'm not gonna really need to use it. And I thought that was such a funny story, because here's someone that I consider the consummate clinician, and he was acknowledging that the step-the-scope was in many ways just sort of a prop. But it's an omnipresent prop.
他说，哦，是的，谢谢，这很完美。他认识我。当他走开时，他说，你知道，病人在看你时只是期望你有这个。他说，我真的不需要使用它。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的故事，因为这是一个我认为是完美的临床医生的人，他承认听诊器在很多方面只是一个道具。但它是一个无处不在的道具。
If you do a Google image search for doctor, right away, you'll notice a couple of things about what a physician is supposed to look like. Most of the doctor's pictures on the first page of results are white men in white coats. Some of them are peering inside of patients' ears. Others are writing something down, an equip board, but all of them have stethoscopes. Well, what I find so intriguing about the Google Images searches for doctor is not only is every doctor wearing a stethoscope,
如果你在谷歌图片搜索“医生”，你会立刻注意到关于医生应该是什么样子的几件事。搜索结果第一页上的大多数医生照片都是穿着白大褂的白人男性。他们中的一些人正在窥视病人的耳朵。其他人正在记下一些东西，一个记事板，但他们所有人都带着听诊器。嗯，我对谷歌图片搜索“医生”感到如此着迷的是，不仅每个医生都戴着听诊器，
but they are almost all wearing the stethoscope in the exact same way, which is like a shawl around the back of the neck. With the earpieces on one side and the bell on the other, Bombak says that this way of wearing a stethoscope draped over the shoulders is a relatively recent fashion trend. The first time I can remember ever seeing that was on the television show ER. And then it on scrubs, which is another very popular medical TV show. Doctors used to wear their stethoscopes dangling down the front of the shirt like a tie. And this was practical. If you needed to use your stethoscope in a hurry, you just popped it into your ears.
而且他们几乎都以完全相同的方式佩戴听诊器，就像脖子后面的一条披肩。听筒在一侧，钟形头在另一侧，邦巴克说，这种把听诊器挂在肩膀上的佩戴方式是一种相对较新的时尚潮流。我记得第一次看到这个是在电视剧《急诊室的故事》中。然后是在《实习医生风云》中，这是另一部非常受欢迎的医疗电视剧。医生过去常把听诊器像领带一样挂在衬衫前面。这很实用。如果你需要匆忙使用听诊器，你只需把它塞进耳朵里。
It's almost like this new version of wearing it like a scarf or a shawl is almost a concession that it's more a fashion accessory than actually a tool that we're using. But even if the stethoscope exam has become something of a ritual, it doesn't mean that doctors are ready to give it up. I mean, I would never give up my stethoscope because I think in the very least, it's this conduit to connecting with the patient. Bombac says that physical contact between a doctor and a patient
这几乎就像这种把它像围巾或披肩一样佩戴的新版本，几乎是一种承认它更多的是一种时尚配饰，而不是我们正在使用的实际工具。但即使听诊器检查已经成为一种仪式，也不意味着医生准备放弃它。我的意思是，我永远不会放弃我的听诊器，因为我认为至少，它是与病人建立联系的渠道。邦巴克说，医生和病人之间的身体接触
has become increasingly rare. Doctors' visits are short, and physicians often spend half the time staring at a computer screen. The stethoscope provides an important opportunity for intimacy. The stethoscope is still a part of the exam that is still very much aligned with that idea
变得越来越罕见。医生的就诊时间很短，医生经常花一半的时间盯着电脑屏幕。听诊器提供了一个亲密接触的重要机会。听诊器仍然是检查的一部分，它仍然与那个想法非常一致
of the laying on of hands that a healer can do. When we go to do the physical exam, we move away from our desk, we move away from the computer, and we stand right next to the patient, and it's a much more intimate conversation. And even with all these powerful tools for measuring what's going on inside a body, We move away from the computer and we stand right next to the patient and it's a much more intimate conversation. And even with all these powerful tools for measuring what's going on inside a body, intimate conversations are still really important in medicine.
即治疗者可以进行的“按手礼”。当我们去做身体检查时，我们离开办公桌，离开电脑，站在病人身边，这是一次更亲密的对话。即使有所有这些测量身体内部情况的强大工具，我们离开电脑，站在病人身边，这是一次更亲密的对话。即使有所有这些测量身体内部情况的强大工具，亲密的对话在医学中仍然非常重要。
Dr. Bombak says he thinks that the stethoscope has come to symbolize to the patient that the doctor is there to listen. And whether we're actually listening to their heart or their lungs is probably not that important, but what they really want to know is that we're listening to what they say. 200 years ago, Renee Linex invention ushered in a new medical era. One with a patient's own understanding of their disease
邦巴克医生说，他认为听诊器已经象征着病人，医生在那里是为了倾听。无论我们是否真的在听他们的心脏或肺部，这可能并不重要，但他们真正想知道的是，我们正在倾听他们所说的话。200年前，拉埃内克的发明开启了一个新的医学时代。一个病人对自己疾病的理解
gave way to more objective observation of the body. This turned put a certain amount of distance between doctors and patients. Today, maybe the stethoscope lives on to keep physicians and patients from drifting too far apart, to make sure doctors keep close to their patients, and keep listening. 99% of this will be back in a heartbeat after these messages. Hey, it's Emmett. I'm back. Okay, so real quick, before we go, remember when I mentioned that there are these new electronic stethoscopes?
让位于对身体更客观的观察。这在医生和病人之间产生了一定的距离。今天，也许听诊器继续存在是为了防止医生和病人漂移得太远，确保医生与病人保持亲近，并保持倾听。《99%隐形》将在这些消息后立刻回来。嘿，我是埃米特。我回来了。好的，那么在离开之前，还记得我提到过有这些新的电子听诊器吗？
Well, one is made by this company Echo, which is based right here in Berkeley. And their stethoscope can record a patient's heartbeat, display the waveform, and they're even working on software that can help doctors identify irregularities. I stop by their offices and ask them to record my heart. They press the device to my chest and a little waveform popped up on a smartphone. At the top here you see the heart start to fire. You actually see that's called the P wave right there. That's echo founder Connor Landgraph. And while he is not a doctor, he says my heart looks healthy.
嗯，其中一个是Echo公司制造的，总部就在伯克利。他们的听诊器可以记录病人的心跳，显示波形，他们甚至正在开发可以帮助医生识别异常的软件。我顺道去了他们的办公室，请他们记录我的心脏。他们把装置按在我的胸口，智能手机上弹出了一个小波形。在顶部这里你看到心脏开始跳动。你实际上看到那叫P波。那是Echo的创始人康纳·兰格拉夫。虽然他不是医生，但他认为我的心脏看起来很健康。
Pretty normal looking waveform. Nothing really interesting looking there. Unfortunately. Unfortunately. Yeah, I guess fortunately for you. Yeah. So just to send us off a very disappointingly boring heartbeat. Sorry, boss. 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, with production help from Delaney
看起来很正常的波形。没什么特别有趣的样子。不幸的是。不幸的是。是的，我想这对你来说是幸运的。是的。所以只是为了送我们走一个非常令人失望的无聊心跳。抱歉，老板。《99%隐形》本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，德莱尼·霍尔和谢丽·福西夫提供了制作帮助。我们的高级制作人是凯蒂·明格尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。其余工作人员包括艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、泰兰·马扎和我罗曼·马尔斯。本周的额外音乐来自我们的朋友Okakumi和Melodyne。特别感谢安娜·普拉格，她为我们激发了这个想法。我们是旧金山91.7 KALA-L-W的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Radio Row制作。
Hall and Sheree Fusif. Our senior producer is Katie Mingle Kurt Colstead is the digital director, The Music, was by Sean Rial. The rest of staff includes Avery Trouffleman, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. Additional music this week by our friends, Okakumi and Melodyne. Special thanks to Anna Prager, who sparked this idea for us. We are a project of 91.7 KALA-L-W and San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
我们是来自PRX的RadioTopia的骄傲创始成员，得到了新闻捍卫之夜基金会和像你一样的硬币携带听众的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目，享受关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我Roman Mars，或者在工作时@99PI。或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也可以。但我们有所有过去的剧集，并且每周在我们的网站99PI.org上至少发布两篇关于设计的文章。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
We are a proud founding member of Radio Topia from PRX supported by the Journalism Defending Night Foundation and coin carrying listeners, just like you. You can find the show, Enjoying Discussions, about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI at work. Or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have all the past episodes and at least two articles about design published on our
我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的创始成员，并得到了新闻捍卫基金会以及像您一样慷慨解囊的听众的支持。您可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目“Enjoying Discussions”。您可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，或关注节目账号@99PI。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上活跃。我们所有的往期节目以及每周至少两篇关于设计的文章都发布在我们的
website every week at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网站99PI.org上。PRX旗下的Radio Topia。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。